bene sul nuovo video di rocket league
siamo con il buon laurentiis in 22 gol
di là ci sono io con il mio normalissimo
nickname quando giocano che videogioco
cazzo cazzo tensione 90 e che
esattamente quello che è nato l'amore
l'open data per scasso che è esattamente
il mio gioco quando in gioco c'è mai
madonna che non mi tolgo quando serve
calcola stato apposto un po 0 napoli
ho guardato bene dove era finita perché
ha subito una sconfitta che fai ma una
buona ma da bellissima e raccontati da
parata mancato cattivissimi entrava
niente a chi taglia taglia taglia
bellissimo ecco la mafia dentro
buono il tocco ottimo il trucco occhi
obama ieri guarda 31 anche il punteggio
13 11 ma trova spingere da spingere
tranquillo bug attivissimo ho visto
altre un po larghi aspettavo un mamma
mia mamma mia mamma mia mamma mia mamma
mi ha proprio lì un [ __ ] doveva del
controllo foto sul tetto anzi sul muro
come si dice detto moore perché tiro
finale magari tiro ma che cosa è proprio
a loro che decidono di portarla lì per
me perché io sono quello prospettato
neanche il velocissimo niente e si sa
che sarà ricavato zio che diciamo
va bene
quasi e tu
un gol e gol no ah sì
51 raga 51 si va a dominare controllino
del favino per poi il pavia la nota
cacchio tranquillo non è senza tour
ancora è stato toro
basta tranquilla tranquilla eccolo
eccolo 61 come dai ragazzi finiamo qui
mi sembra un po ridicola sotto al centro
tra su tutto
basta un cacchio perché l'attenzione
scazzo fortissimo
niente niente va bene dove andare a
questo che all'inizio perché salve
buongiorno niente correndo non esisteva
fino allo fino all'ultimo gioca te la
passo bomba che però prendiamolo un palo
così che dite no l'ex marito escono
dall'altro lato aggredisci non si
sacrifica tutto con merda la postina
diretto saluto dall'auto tantissimo
ufficio nostra prima magari detto mi
sono caricato lamentato non si rubano
parte questa la partenza in creano le
ranesi ma non si scopre che ci sono
state come dove tu questa tappa nuova
non ho pagato e questo non va bene
io non so cosa sto facendo soprattutto
non giocherò contro l'idea meno quello
può anche farlo amici nemici di
confronti e trapasso fi grazie al turbo
ma ci provo
perché ci credo ho buone top nel cielo
libero pretende di un busto e me ne vado
ma quasi hanno portato a peccato non ci
disse che stop occhio i banchi dopo i
tumori
si chiuderebbe adesso ce l'ho adesso che
gol come è entrato st palla che non
tutto semplice erano in due libri a ok
va bene sembra tv lì io posso provare a
fare un non so che ci prova prima di
roma fi
no ma poco demonio era facile dovrebbe
fare il cattivissimo ci provava lo zio
ben sa chi lo zio mirata quell'angolino
sono andrea pirlo ma che beffa bene
invece non sa i costi tiri puliti
beh io me ne vado io perché se ci sono
sono spinto ok va bene va bene
quattro a zero così è tanto di l'est per
l'altro di mastro el'altra rimane finale
ok nostro più sia aria che oggi è finito
al video di rocket lead quel gioco con
le macchine bello molto carino comunque
non ho mai fatto troppo bello bello
grazie di cassano ritis per aver
partecipato i schede a cannes ha
lasciato un bel mi piace e noi cosa ci
vediamo a professioni e ragazzi
[Musica]